hi everyone welcome to our daily
homeroom for those of you who don't know
what this is this is really a live
stream that we started during co vid but
have kept up I guess still going on but
it's really a way to have interesting
conversations or just to kind of
interact with each other and talk about
interesting things today we're actually
going to have an ask me anything which
we've done a couple of times before I
really enjoy it hopefully you enjoy it
as well so start thinking of your
questions put them on the message boards
whether you're watching it on YouTube or
Facebook and we have team members who
can look at those messages and they'll
surface it to me but it literally could
be about anything I like some of the
questions that are a little bit out of
out of left field but before we begin
let me give my standard announcement or
thanks to several corporations that have
stepped up in the run-up actually as
soon as they found out that we were
already running at a deficit pre-coated
and that with kovat our destiny has
grown even more special thanks to Bank
for America Google org ATT fastly and
Novartis and even with that help we're
still running at a deficit so if you're
in a position to do so please think
about donating to Khan Academy every
donation helps and that's what allows us
to keep it free non-commercial and reach
tens of millions of students around the
world who otherwise would not have
access to really world-class learning in
a personalized way with interactive
software etcetera etcetera but with that
I would love to take some questions and
so let me see what questions are
starting to come in and actually before
I even start answering questions I will
give a little bit of an announcement
some of you know that I've been doing
this it's not an official Khan Academy
project maybe one day it will be it's
very complementary to Khan Academy
schoolhouse dot world and the idea there
it actually it was it's myself and some
volunteers have been putting that
together and that is a way to match
students who need help who need tutoring
with volunteer tutors and it's
interesting I have talked about it
before where I said hey if your tutor
you can volunteer if your student we
actually have more tutors than students
and so if you need tutoring there is an
opportunity especially on high school
level subjects there's an opportunity
for free tutoring at schoolhouse dot
world so I encourage and we're expanding
it
started in calculus but now we're
expanding at Algebra one algebra
geometry precalculus trigonometry or
calculus so pretty much any high school
math subject if you want three tutoring
there's a great opportunity to get it at
schoolhouse dot world so check that out
there'll be a little form you have to
apply to be get in because it's still at
kind of a very alpha early stage but
it's a great way and you know my hope is
that we were able to create a critical
mass of both volunteer tutors and
students who need help and that over
time especially is when we get into
back-to-school above-and-beyond Khan
Academy where you can get help at your
own time and pace you could get practice
and feedback and you can get videos that
there's also a place to get free
in-person I guess you could say
virtually in person or over
videoconference / zoom help so please
please check that out so especially if
your student incidentally so I see the
questions that are coming in so from
youtube osama al-safi says how many
hours of Aish is a successful student
study and then actually from YouTube Sun
Jae Suk's Noreen says what helps you
what helps you study more effectively
and so these are related questions I
would say anything in life that you want
to get good at if you're able to put in
a minimum of twenty thirty minutes a day
you would be surprised how far you can
get so if you're just trying to say
let's just say pick map if you're just
trying to get better at math you
literally do twenty thirty minutes a day
you will get better at math especially
on Khan Academy working at your own time
and pace now there's certain things then
just to get started up and get into the
flow takes a little bit more than thirty
minutes like if you wanted to learn to
be a programmer or become a great writer
but even then it's about regular
practice it's about just showing up and
starting to write whether it's writing a
creative writing story or whether it's
writing some code and there you might do
a longer stretch due to three hours at a
time or even if you're really in the
zone do several hours but once again is
it's all about the regularity of it if
you are give an exam the next day
you know obviously revolve it in those
situations where we have to cram a
little bit you know I and I'm guilty of
of doing what I'm telling you not to do
but I think sleep is very important so I
wouldn't go I wouldn't study into your
normal sleep time and the reason is not
only will you be more rested the next
day sleep is when a lot of those neural
connections are forming in your brain
it's when your subconscious has a chance
to really process a lot of that
information and so I find that you know
I could study a good bit and if I get a
good night's sleep when I wake up in the
morning not only am i refresh but my
brain actually has understood the
material in the strange way a lot better
so from YouTube part sha asks what do
you use donations for good question
parsed so you know a lot of you
associate Khan Academy with things that
maybe I have done made videos etc etc
but what you might not appreciate and I
think I get undue credit is that Khan
Academy is over 200 full-time people and
you might then say why does kind of kind
of me need 200 full-time people well
first think about the number of subjects
and grades that we are covering at Khan
Academy you know we have Khan Academy
kids for early learners then we go into
elementary school middle school and high
school even early college that is many
many we have over forty thirty
grade-level years of of courses so to
speak so there's a lot of content there
that we try to cover as comprehensively
as possible it's not just creating the
videos it is creating exercises for
every skill for every standard and when
we create exercises we don't just create
two or three per standard we create 20
or 30 so that you can get as much
practice as you need most students will
not see all of the items on Khan Academy
but in case they need more practice we
have that practice then on top of that
when you have a site that is serving 20
30 million people every month
it actually takes pretty technical
sophistication just the server cost on
Khan Academy pre kovat cost about five
six million
dollars a year with kovat our traffic
has increased by a factor of two to
three and so then you can imagine our
server costs are on track to being the
the ten so you know approaching ten a
million or even crossing ten million a
year then on top of that all that
software that you see on Khan Academy
that's free that's non-commercial the
teacher dashboard the interactive the
game mechanics being able to keep track
of what you know and what you don't know
and give you as much practice as you
need in order to write software that can
scale to that many people you need a
very good engineering team and a
reasonably sized engineer keep so we
have 80 engineers and you might say 80
engineers what are they all working on
well think about all of the back-end
infrastructure to keep something up and
running like this think about the
constant improvements we want to do in
the user interface and you know like any
piece of software there are bugs that we
have to constantly fix then on top of
that think about the different grade
levels and modalities on Khan Academy
we're also the official practice for the
SAT so and we're also the official
practice for the LSAT and that has a
slightly different software experience
so that's where the engineering and then
obviously working with engineers we have
designers product managers and then we
have a philanthropy team that obviously
there's to raise money so you might say
you know part that we do need to pay
their salaries and then you know we have
like a partnerships team where we need a
partner with folks like the College
Board or Al sac or other groups to make
sure in school districts to make sure
that Khan Academy is having the maximum
impact we have an efficacy and research
team where we're constantly trying to
study how Khan Academy is impacting
people and how we can get better at that
we have an amp data analytics team
that's looking at the data oftentimes in
conjunction with the efficacy research
team to understand how we can get better
and then of course you just need a
subgroup of leaders to help manage all
of this all of this stuff so hopefully
that explains it but I will say this is
kind of in the spirit of me asking for
money if you're in a position to do so
our budget is the budget of a large high
school but obviously Khan Academy
reaches many many many more than then
you know then that would apply a social
return on investment of Khan Academy is
very very very large and
you can do some calculations on that
however you want to calculating it it's
very large hopefully so from Facebook
Patricia at sing COO asks what is your
favorite food
so that might seem like a simple
question but my wife will tell you for
me it's very complex and there's a lot
of soul-searching because there are
things that my animal brain wants to eat
that I know are not good for me and then
when I eat them it creates this whole
cycle of guilt and so it's not clear
whether net-net there's benefits to it
so I do have a sweet tooth you know I
think I've grown up eating some South
Asian desserts that I especially like
like I don't know familiar with uh in
Bengali we say Russia bula Hindi
speakers would say Russia Gilad kind of
a kind of a I don't know a cottage
cheese milk sphere in in is that that
kind of boiled in syrup as you can
imagine for someone who has a family
history of diabetes that is not a good
thing to be eating but that is one of my
favorites there's also another South
Asian dessert known as Russa malai also
one of my favorite but not a good thing
to eat so I've been lately trying to
actually cut out all sugar the way I
work I find abstinence is easier than
moderation that it's a very debatable
thing I'm curious to see whether you'll
feel whether at how you feel on that
spectrum whether it's easier to be
moderate or whether it's easier to be
extreme but for me if you just cut it
out so I've been trying to be more I
guess you could say ketogenic but in
that spirit I've been able to find some
good I've been ordering from Costco I
thought you do not like some sponsors
but I've eaten one of these kind of keto
chocolate they're kind of like Klondike
bars you know with a stick but they're
ketogenic they have like no sugar no
carbs in them so that is my current
favorite food that is my daily
indulgence so far okay another thing
that I really enjoy is rose milk so take
some milk a little rose water in it and
then if you don't know what rose water
is you can usually buy it like the local
international store
or oftentimes a Persian store iranian
store and then I put monk fruit which is
my kind of natural sugar substitute very
good very good if you're not worried
about sugar just look regular sugar in
there that's another one of my favorite
drinks but as you could see I have a
sweet tooth so DLX coating 247 says on
YouTube do you read the YouTube chat
well the very fact that I've just read
your comment implies that I am able to
read some of it alright
hikaru so from YouTube says how can I
get a job in this economy how to get a
job after college that's a really good
question a Caruso you know I don't know
your your particular circumstance or
skillset or what you're hoping to get a
job in or where you live but you know my
general advice for getting a job you
know when I came out of college it was a
very hot job market it was in the late
90s and I had a degree in computer
science and math and so I found it was
you know it was almost like a it was it
was it was a bounty of opportunity then
when I graduated from business school
that was in 2003 that job market I think
was much more similar to the job market
that's starting to emerge now that was
one of the worst job markets and you
know I remember when I graduated from
business school the Career Services said
this is the worst job market they saw
for MBA since the early 70s and my
attitude towards that is just keep
putting yourself out there my when I
graduate from business school you know
my been fiance my wife she was in New
York so I really wanted to work in New
York and I applied and I really wanted
to work in finance I wanted work at a
hedge fund and I applied probably a
hundred places I probably ended up
getting 20 or 30 interviews and I got
none of the jobs so it was not it's not
a pleasant experience but it's just
every day I just said okay I'm gonna
submit this number of resumes I'm going
to write this number of cover letters
I'm going to just put myself out there
and just every every job interview every
rejection that's a learning experience
and it took a while but eventually I
found you know there was a
a guy he was you know I was 26 at the
time he was 33 he was starting a small
hedge fund in Boston which wasn't ideal
because it was a you know 200 miles away
from where my where my fiancee lived but
he gave me a he gave me an opportunity
finally and you know so that was
probably the 30th interview that I that
I had but you know if I didn't get that
I was looking at other opportunities I
was looking at this you know I needed
some way I didn't want to graduate and
just not have some way to pay off my dad
and pay my bills and you know pay you
live so I was looking at whatever
opportunities you know sometimes you can
get very fixated in a particular
industry or particular job type as I had
with hedge funds but I realized at the
end the other day it was very important
for me to make a living
one way or the other so you can you know
even though it's good to keep trying at
whatever that aspiration is I definitely
was looking at jobs that maybe paid less
but I still felt I could learn something
from and build my experience because I
would see any pay was better than no pay
so I would always index on a job where
you'll learn new things where people
invest in you and if they pay decent or
pay fairly then that's great as well but
it's more about especially early stage
in your career are you going to be able
to grow are you going to be able to
learn important skill set other things
that I would recommend doing is you know
just be your authentic self you know
keep if you can show artifacts of things
that you have done you know this is the
world when in 2003 when I was applying
that was I think it was pre YouTube and
all of that you know today you could
create screenshots of work that you've
made and explain it and that has two
benefits people will see the work that
you've created and they can also see you
explaining it which has you know that
shows that you have communication skills
and other things and so yeah the more
artifacts you can create of your of your
work product the better and I think
that'll make you help you stick out if
there's you know a lot of resumes that
they're sifting through so let's see
from Facebook Osama is smile Sal what
are your strengths as a teacher
you know it's hard to say that you ever
fully know yourself but I would say my
strengths are I usually have a love for
whatever I'm teaching in fact I don't
think I would teach any I don't try to
teach something unless I'm personally
excited about it and I think passion and
curiosity is infectious I'm a naturally
curious person so I don't view teaching
as let me just you know regurgitate
something and hope the other person gets
it I view teaching as let me show or
help this other person discover how
exciting this is and how intriguing it
is and how this is connected with the
universe and how it helps understand our
place in the universe I would say the
other aspects are you know I I try to
bring when I explain something I tried
to bring kind of a comfort to it you
know a relaxation to it so when you
watch a Khan Academy video or if I'm
teaching in person I try to use a tone
that I'm using now I don't use like the
next step of this equation is when the
you know that I think stresses the
situation and when folks are stressed
it's harder to engage in the material
and I would say the last thing is in
this course it's close to the first
thing is I do believe that that you
could have done things best when you
understand the intuition and when you
can see how they're connected to other
things and so I definitely try to do
that as much as possible I do it for my
own brain to understand that so my brain
works and I think it's helpful for other
brains as well so let's see other
questions here is so primate honey from
YouTube says how do I maximize my
writing potential I'm not you know of
writing expert but I would say it goes
to one of the earlier question I think
you can't go wrong with that just keep
writing keep practicing the craft and
then put yourself out there show it to
people get feedback from people
obviously ideally feedback from folks
who can give you constructive feedback
books like teachers other people who's
writing you really like and when they
give you feedback it's human nature to
get defensive I get defensive at least
in my mind would something says wait you
can send just said I'm right nobody does
that furries
and you don't see how genius it is or
whatever but recognize feedback is a
gift and you don't have to take you know
not everyone feedback is 100 percent
right there's amazing writers who you
know an early point in their life
someone told them yeah you're not been
good at this or a seller said oh don't
take that - sure - just keep writing
when people give you feedback really try
to listen to what they're saying keep
iterating on what you're creating and I
think if you do that you'll you'll
become a you know you have a good chance
of becoming a great writer so let's see
prasad kota from youtube says mr. kaan
what is a good topic to do to expand
your creativity good question i don't
know if i have like any like clear
answer i think one thing is that you
need time to truly be creative I think
in our world today it's very easily very
easy to get over scheduled and when you
get over scheduled you could be doing
productive things you could be learning
things even but creativity really
sometimes comes out of boredom it comes
out of like what do I do with myself for
the next two hours and I think that's a
very important muscle I think other
things that I like a you know surround
yourself with other creative folks who
like to brainstorm you like to think
outside of the box or don't even see the
box and if you don't have them around
you seek people out on on the internet
like that and if you watch a lot of TED
talks you'll see a lot of creative
people and how they think about things
and there's a lot of lot of people on
YouTube even people who are doing you
know kind of fun silly things they're
incredibly creative and and you can tell
if maybe I could do something like that
and and but at the same time you know
build up your skills you know you might
want to go into the visual arts to be a
great visual artist you need to be
creative and it is nice to have some
core skills if you want to be a great
mathematician you have to be creative
but it's also useful to have some core
baseline skills you want to be a great
writer creativity is huge but it's great
also to be able to write well
communicate well and have decent grammar
so that's that's the best advice I could
give you but there's nothing like
surrounding yourself with other creative
people and kind of feeding off of that
so from Facebook side alsa hosta thank
you for your work how do you find which
subjects
to be taller which aren't taught yet how
do you keep track of what students need
so I think the question is how do we
decide on kind of what to prioritize
next we look at you know our vision is
to cover all the core academic subjects
from pre-k through college so that's the
universe so that's math science social
sciences and language arts in turn with
in that and I hope in 10 years we have
all of that but within that we
prioritize what subjects are we capable
of doing well
especially capable of doing well given
the modalities that we do we have at our
Khan Academy today and what are subjects
that we know a lot of students have
difficulty in or could use extra support
or don't have access to world-class
materials and so that's why math was
kind of an obvious first place to start
and then we were moving into the
sciences some social sciences it's kind
of gone in that order but that's what we
thought about it and we say you know
what the core academic subject we view
it as something that most students take
or need to take if they want to keep
progressing academically so you know in
k-12 that you're your math all the way
through maybe calculus or statistics and
then if you go to the college-level
calculus statistics may be things like
differential equations multivariable
calculus these are things that most
people if they go into a stem career for
sure are going to take if you think
about the scientist chemistry physics
biology at both the high school and
college levels to go to college maybe
organic chemistry as well you know if
you look at the social sciences the
world histories the civics you know I
would love at some point to do law you
know you can debate whether econ is a
social science or kind of a traditional
science but econ psychology is something
that many students take so these are
like we don't have psychology on Khan
Academy yet everything else I mentioned
we do but we now have psychology but
that is something that I think would be
something that we would eventually do so
that's how we think about it and so
let's see Minelli Hernandez from
facebook says thank you for Khan camp
2020 my three children are enjoying and
learning a lot great for those who don't
know what camp camp Khan is it's a way
to keep everyone learning over the
summer if you do a web search for camp
Khan you'll see the resources they are
in it's a way to keep kids in gay
as they do our get ready for grade level
courses which I highly recommend for any
student your parent or teacher out there
who needs to get students ready for
grade level so Siddhartha from YouTube
says how to keep focused on academics in
between in between so much going on in
the world what you know I I definitely
empathize with what you're saying I
think there's so much in the world some
of it in our locus of control so to
speak we can do something about some of
it and depends who we are that degree we
can do something about it but then
there's so much else in the world
especially if you watch the news can you
know make you anxious make you worried
about things but you really can't do
much now it's important to be informed
you don't want to just stick your head
enough in a hole and pretend like the
rest of the world is not there but what
I try to do is stay informed you know I
try to quarantine it's not to overuse
the word reading the news and things
like that to about you know max 30
minutes a day but the rest of the day
you know I many of y'all know I meditate
every day that's a way for me to clear
my mind to steal my mind and then just
focus on putting one foot in front the
other and say what is in my zone of
control that can make myself or the
world around me better and then I say
let me do it and what I find is if I
start my day early and I start taking
action and I start having small wins
then that builds momentum so those small
wins
could be you know I got my meditate had
a good meditation first thing in the
morning I went for a run first I run I
try to run a mile every day so it's not
like long distance running but I run a
mile as fast as I can every day make my
bed I do first thing in the morning and
so when I build these winds you know if
I'm able to make a video or two in the
morning you know by 9:00 in the morning
ten in the morning I'm like okay I made
my bed I got ready I I went for a run I
meditated I made two three videos then
all of a sudden I see I say you know
what Sal you are a productive human
being and yes there's stuff going on in
the world but just keep at it you're
making your positive dent either on
yourself or around the world so that's
how I attempt to think about it but
obviously we all have times that you
just feel a little bit you know we the
veg or just process so there's
questions from Facebook Maya with itch
says always wanted to pick at your
reading list what are your favorite
writers and then there's another
question Osama from smile second
question from Osama Facebook what are
your favorite books novels I've answered
this in different ways before whoops if
you look back here there are some of my
favorite book you'll see some Isaac
asked them off right over here I love
the foundation series for multiple
reasons that more and more Isaac Asimov
done here you'll see a lot of kind of
epic space science fiction here and I I
love that cuz it just expands your
worldview or your universal view beyond
the day to day that we all live in and
we can all of us get kind of caught up
with like oh gotta pay the mortgage
gotta you know go to work go to the
meetings you know there's just a
day-to-day some of its good some of it
is this kind of tedious but then it's
great to get into these universes where
like what but wow there's this whole you
know time and space and what's our
purpose and I feel like it elevates them
you know that previous question about
creativity I find when you we read
science fiction when sometimes fantasy
as well it takes your creativity to
another level because you view
everything you by definition these these
types of stories break outside of the
bounds of traditional thinking so in
that realm
Isaac asked him off you know dune
Herbert so you know he's doing is one of
my favorite books arthur c clarke almost
anything he's written i'm a big fan of
in the science-fiction realm if you go
outside of science fiction i love
actually Jane Austen Pride and Prejudice
most famously I like Kurt Vonnegut big
fan you know it well yeah there's
there's there's a you know Candide by
Voltaire if we were to go into a little
bit of the classic I love Don Quixote
you know it's I
strangely relate to him in a lot of
levels talk about someone who's living
in their own reality so those are the
ones those are the ones that that that
stick out for me
so Misha
Natarajan from YouTube says do you ever
burn out you know depends on you define
its burn out
there's definitely been times in my life
where I felt tired and stretched and I
said I just need a break and you know
what and and it happened it kind of
creeps up at you on you you know you're
you're doing well and then a little
you're getting a little tired little
bored but like no this is super
important I'm going to power through it
and before you know it you're really not
in a good place you're you're crabby or
you know you're snapping at people
you're you're not assuming positive
intent of others your brain is just kind
of constantly worried about something
and I've tried to become much more aware
of when I'm falling into that you know
the meditation helps a lot I think you
know we keep we oftentimes it's a global
culture now but it's all definitely a
Western culture in American culture
you know push yourself to the limit your
work is everything and you know when you
when you are lucky enough to work on the
social mission it sometimes does feel
like the work is everything there's
millions of people who need this help
etcetera etc but you also have to remind
yourself no matter what your job is if
you truly burnout that's not going to
help anybody so I've been learning to
take it a little bit easier have you
know have my weekends to really rest and
recuperate there was a time in my life
even in Khan Academy where I would kind
of just keep working because I am so
passionate about this mission but you
know spending 2-3 days with family and
friends and just doing nothing getting
your head into a different place very
very very important and every every year
I get older I realize just how much more
important to do so highly recommend
meditation highly recommend breaks and
giving yourself every day a little bit
of time to do something that's unrelated
with your core work and every week spend
a day or two at least to kind of take
your mind someplace else you have to do
it and I think you'll actually find
you'll get more work done in your in
your in your in your regular work so
let's see so many to question I'd wear
all right we're already at time let's
see there's Prasad
then I play any sports when I was young
I played all you know I wasn't your your
typical super athlete type person I you
know I played in the neighborhood with
other kids in the apartment you know
that I lived in the only sport I ever
did kind of an organized way I was on
the wrestling team in tenth grade and I
enjoyed I wasn't bad but my only trophy
of substance in wrestling was having the
highest GPA on the wrestling team so you
can take that for what for it bad note I
will let every this is this is one I
always really enjoy these athlete
anything hopefully y'all enjoy too but
I'm late for a meeting I just realized
so I thank everyone for joining tomorrow
we're going to have our head of
engineering I know they have that
earlier question about what does
everyone do at Khan Academy so we're
going to have our head of engineering
Marta talk about our engineering work
and what we hope to do there at Khan
Academy and then on Wednesday we have
another really really interesting
conversation around really just
childhood and how students are raised
and the effect on their psyche and
things like that so I look forward to
seeing y'all at future homeroom